training meteorologist ted florento
joining us now during our four o'clock
show you always have great facts you
bring in you know before you give us the
eight day you know i've got i'm full of
worthless information no
low
oh
we call it the flow factor this is
getting some traction so i've been
putting stuff on things that i know and
i've learned and i call it the flow
facts and it's been getting uh some
really good retweets we're learning a
lot
you have to you guys and all the other
anchors have been commenting so here's
some okay here's the latest one wind
doesn't make a sound until it blows
against an object
right here's another one the atlantic
ocean is saltier than the pacific ocean
confirmation christian you lived on the
coast yes right but we both lived on
both coasts yes i can't tell the
difference
i swallowed both
but yeah that's true more salinity in
the atlantic ocean the red sea has the
most obviously but yeah more flow facts
will put that out on social media for
everybody to share with your friends
maybe your local bar you can say you're
smarter than your other friend
by seeing some of the full facts 74
degrees in teddy hills right now 74 7176
for the lakes double sevens for downtown
79 sunrise manor double sevens for green
valley 74 for henderson 771 for seven
hills southern highlands here at 69
degrees in road rancho mountains at 74.
that's a lot of neighborhoods 72 indian
springs 70 for searchlight 81 falafel
look at this we're in the 90s in death
valley trying to get up there in that
heat but will not reach triple digits
satellite radar clear skies right now
and that goes all the way over to
southern california arizona there too
even central california they got some
rain early this week now clearing up all
that rain in the pacific northwest
changing over the snow in the cascade
mountains i used to do a lot of
snowboarding in the cascade mountains
good to see some of that there high
pressure to the south west of us that's
going to warm us up again and bring us
to near record territory and that's what
we're eyeing for this weekend so numbers
back up to the 80s in some neighborhoods
78 for friday officially 79 for saturday
sunday 81. if that's the case that will
tie the record for that day that will
also be the warmest day also this week
with 81 degrees before those numbers
start to drop for next week here are
your wins for tomorrow too staying light
as we wrap up the work week so don't
expect any big wind gusts unless you're
down to lord's loft in bullhead city
where you continue to see those strong
gusty winds and that will continue also
through your weekend 57 overnight clear
and nice with light winds light breezes
tomorrow 78 sunny and another day of
above average temperatures look at that
almost 10 degrees above normal we'll
keep around some of those north breezes
for tomorrow highs neighborhood by
neighborhood in the mid to high 80s or
70s i should say for tomorrow 77 north
las vegas along with spring valley and
southern highlands 74 for summerlin
we'll be at 80 green valley 76 for
henderson and 75 for prompt mosquito
coming in at 79 degrees just shy of 80
tomorrow in the afternoon eight day
forecast showing lots of sunshine there
are those records on saturday and sunday
like we said we'll come very close to
that next week we're cooling things off
back to normal for those of you want the
cooler numbers and look at this some 60s
finally
on the eight day forecast later on the
week next week
that is your most accurate weather guys
over here it's a nice range yes all
right if you